Democrat Adam Frisch who almost I mean
really almost almost defeated and
removed from Congress radical republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert is running
again in 2024. now I am not a political
strategist I can't tell you whether it
is wise to announce this early for Adam
Frisch I just have no idea but what I
can assure you is that as close as we
came in 2022 there's going to be another
opportunity to remove Lauren bobert
democrats should rally behind Adam
Frisch it would be a really great thing
we got rid of Madison cawthorne bobert
and Marjorie Taylor green were
re-elected we have another opportunity
in 2024 let's see if we can kick bobert
out because she really brings nothing
positive to the table